trois attaques peut-être cette nous
dit-on de source policière en tout cas
au moins trois ont été perpétrés à paris
et autour de paris
on n'a jamais connu un attentat comme ça
dans les rues de paris on n'a jamais été
confronté à une action ans de guerre
[Musique]
c'est la guerre avec l'odeur de la
poudre du sang la vision c'est la guerre
on pense pas trop hein soit on l'a on
essaie surtout de prendre les bonnes
décisions
déterminées qui a fait quoi
comment
avec qui et pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est une toile de quoi ça s'est passé
tellement énorme je pars de trois
personnes qui nous ont tiré dessus un an
après on me parle d'une quantité de gens
on me parle du financement des armes de
tout vient énorme
45000 code 45 mille pièces de procédure
mille sept cent quarante parties civiles
et 350 avocat ce jour au moins six mois
d'audiences dans une salle de 600 places
spécialement construite au coeur du
palais de justice de paris
c'est un procès de très grande ampleur
et qui donc nue comparable à rien ce
procès on n'a pas le choix il doit être
historique
que n'at-on pas fait que n'at-on pas
empêché comment ces attentats ont ils pu
se produire
c'est la liberté qui aura le dernier mot
vous avez agi de manière effroyable vous
allez être condamné de manière
démocratique
[Musique]
non
à
théoriquement la date de fin des
chantiers c'est quand exactement alors
les travaux sont achevés la lenteur de
la nuit jour mi juin d'accord
et
[Musique]
hazim non
c'est vraiment
vraiment très très bon
voilà donc l'intérieur de la salle
dorénavant achevée ça c'est vraiment une
très très belle idée et je dois dire que
ce qui me plaît bien c'est que l'esprit
de ce palais de justice est complètement
respecté et je suis absolument certain
que tous nos partenaires donc les
avocats à la presse judiciaire auront
bien cette perception d'être dans une
enceinte de justice solennel
aujourd'hui le défi relevé on est dans
les temps malgré plusieurs aléas dont
notamment celui de la crise sanitaire le
calendrier a été tenu au jour près donc
pour nous la mission ayant qui
donc ce qui est important de bien
comprendre c'est qu'une défense
évidemment doit être à côté des accusés
donc la défense se situe à gauche
trente et une place pour la défense pour
quatorze accusés
à droite les 42 places pour les avocats
de parties civiles directement concernés
au moment de telle ou telle partie du
procès avec forcément une rotation
puisqu'il y à 300 avocats qui sont
d'ores et déjà partie au procès il ya
évidemment plus on avance plus il ya des
sujets qui sont peut-être moins
compliqué que la construction d'une
salle d'audience que l'acoustique que
que tous les gros sujets lourds de
construction d'une salle donc c'est
maintenant les sujets moins importants
mais c'est ces sujets-là garantiront la
réussite pour être vécu comme un échec
j'aurais tendance à dire que je suis
plutôt confiant
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous on se réunit
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de groupes de
travail qu'on a appelé deux côtés
d'aquarelles avocat un référent pour le
procès du 13 novembre comme j'ai déjà
dit un certain nombre de fois et en tout
cas à ce qu'on a rencontrés avant la
construction de cette salle c'est
vraiment une une succession de compromis
on essaie de faire vous pourrez pas
venir avec x collaborateurs chacun côté
défense où on vous a dit qu'on vous
assurez donc et place sa tablette
pupitre à au moins deux avocats par
accuser je vous ai parlé des deux
banques qui sont derrière concrètement
on arrivera à trois places avocat par
accuser objectif c'est de faire le point
avec l'ensemble des acteurs concernés il
y a plein de l'infini détails à régler
mais ces détails là après quand il quand
il s'agrègent eh ben ils font ils font
le procès je me permets elle va
intervenir c'est pas un caprice on a
plus de pain dans ce dossier du côté de
la défense être une personne à connaître
tout le dossier c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas de la logistique qui devrait
déterminer notre présence et les
modalités notre présence mais les
besoins de la défense je l'entends on va
voir si on peut pas passer à un 4 look à
part accusé mais ça il faut aussi vous
entendez que c'est pas juste juste x et
au détriment de la place pour les
avocats partie civile pour les parties
civiles et le voir pour la presse donc
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que c'est
toujours histoire de compromis
les mêmes avocats parties civiles auront
certainement les mêmes arguments que
vous on souhaiterait que le grand nombre
des avocats de parties civiles soient le
moins mal coordonnée possible et pour ça
il faut qu'on ait un petit espace où
celui qui est je pense avoir la question
génial à poser etc puisse venir voir ses
petits camarades qui vont lui dire non
mais attends ça c'est déjà traité par
intel et c est pour ça il faut qu'on ait
des lieux pour se parler en cours
d'audience on demande un petit en me
demandant à faire de grands bureaux où
vous serez 3,4 enfin c'est ça les plus
petites salles va donc surveiller ses 60
ans capacité est ce que si on vous
réserver une salle de 60 vous seriez ah
ouais mais attendez pas ce que fit la
personne contrepartie c'est en cela je
vous enlève des finances 50 places dans
la salle d'audience principales courses
50 places de quoi tu avec un parti sans
réponse est non mais vous un jour on n'y
touche pas
nous refusons ce deal
est apte à tintin top il ya quatre
micros seulement qui peuvent marcher en
même temps ça montre déjà qu'il ya un
brouhaha
on peut pas satisfaire tout le monde on
le sait un pro c'est pareil c'est
forcément des forces contradictoires qui
s'opposent on pourra pas donner
satisfaction à tout le monde du fait
simplement du nombre de personnes qui
sont attendues on attend des centaines
de journalistes on attend des milliers
de
parties civiles autres victimes il y
aura sans doute un public nombreux on a
plus de 300 avocats qui sont constitués
la procédure et notre salle d'audience
aussi grande soit elle ne peut contenir
que ses 1 150 personnes là encore le
plus dur est le gros enjeu ça va être au
début du procès on a parlé du roulement
qu'on pourra organiser pour que les
parties civiles soit dans la salle
d'audience principal parce que je veux
éviter c'est la cohue et des
embouteillages ou autres uniquement pour
est arrivé dans la salle d'audience
principal et je profite de la présence
des représentants de l'association pour
redire mais vous le savez déjà que pour
la majorité de vos adhérents qui sont
déjà constitué le premier jour et j'ai
envie de vous dire même les deux trois
premiers jours sont d'un intérêt très
limité à l'audience
[Musique]
tous les accusés qui comparaissent
détenus seront dans ce box des bandes
avocat pour les parties civiles la
débande avocat pour l'accusation est
plus là on a tout le public qui va
s'étirer sur une salle très très longue
alors ça c'est la salle principale
avec une capacité qui sera qui ne
permettra pas d'accueillir un tous les
jours tout le temps toutes les victimes
il revient mais après le problème c'est
vrai tu peux pas enfin bon voilà on a le
droit à notre process et notre procès
oui c'est notre moment et si ça se
trouve on pourra pas accéder à la salle
villa non mais c'est un problème quand
même point c'est un problème je voyais
déjà t'as pas envie d'aller au procès
ont déjà tu sais en plus
franchement ça va être la bataille tu
vas pas que c'est dallas après ce qui
est certain aussi c'est que toutes les
victimes ne viendront pas tous les jours
ouais ça c'est sûr et certain l'avenir
s'éclaircit benoît est très intéressé
par toutes les victimes ne viendront pas
pendant les voyages des victimes et par
contre toutes les victimes viendront sur
la personnalité des accusés le contexte
cyrières parce que si c'est pour
assister dans la salle de retransmission
tu dis je viens pas
si bien sûr je viens mais moi je alors
le choix de deux de faire face oui aux
accusés de faire face au président du
tribunal de faire face aux avocats oui
mais je n'aurai pas le choix
cole hypothèse
où il y a
une très grande influence pour le procès
nous nous sommes organisés pour
mobiliser un très grand nombre de salles
d'audience au delà de celles ci donc
jusqu'à 17 salles d'audience en première
chambre
ce sera une salle d'audience qui
permettra
aux parties civiles qui n'auront pas pu
être dans cette salle de pouvoir
intervenir en vidéo directement avec des
débats donc il y aura une liaison vidéo
entre la salle principale est la
première chambre civile personne ne peut
imaginer que
des parties civiles pourront consacrer
six mois de leur vie à suivre les débats
en venant au palais de justice et avec
pendant la procureure générale nous
avons convaincu la chancellerie
d'adopter ce qu'on appelle une web radio
ce qui permettrait aux parties civiles
de suivre les débats de sans avoir à
venir au palais de justice
quelques mots sur la web radio c'est ce
qu'elle est question d observation sur
ces points là l'idée globale et que tout
est diffusé
oui très clairement l'idée c'est que
tous les débats sont retransmis via la
web radio avec le différé d'une heure
comme vous le savez est différée d'une
heure il a été prévu pour éviter une
diatribe
d'un accusé sur l'état islamique par
exemple des menaces ou un trouble à
l'ordre public
donc c'est tout on est d'accord on veut
témoigner
oui après y avoir beaucoup réfléchi
après m'être dit que mon témoignage
n'avait pas d'intérêt par rapport à
d'autres témoignages qui étaient
certainement plus importants et
en fait
je me suis dit comme vous l'avez dit
aussi que c'est aussi mon procès autant
que toutes les parties civiles et que ma
parole n'avait ni plus ni moins de
valeur que les autres mais enfin pas
plus mais pas moins d'entre eux oui
l'enjeu il est pour vous surtout cinq
semaines de gens qui m'ont pleurer ça va
prendre à m difficile j'ai vu je
deuxième et ce sera moins difficile que
les photos de la fosse c'est vrai il ya
un risque d'effet de répétition par les
témoignages mais moi ça ne me gêne pas
c'est à dire que selon son vécu selon
l'endroit où on est selon la façon dont
ça s'est passé chacun va avoir un trauma
qui est le sien celle que vous n'êtes
pas vous ne devez pas être un nombre
vous êtes des gens et donc à nous à nous
l'institution l'état la justice de
mettre en place les moyens pour que ça
ça puisse exister
tu étais rieurs anjou et tolérant à
l'ecoute borné sur certains sujets
joueurs aimant trop grand pour te faire
des bisous ou pas assez pour voir ta
grandeur d'âme ce vendredi ne l'ont même
pas vu cette grandeur d'âme et ne l'ont
même pas chercher car il défend des leur
idéologie islamique en carton avec des
oeillères qui cachaient leur cerveau
lavé par des discours non fondées
je me conforte dans l'idée que
maintenant vous vous éclaterez au
concert des plus grands disparus
freddie mercury jim morrison kurt cobain
et bien d'autres vous continuerez de
vivre comme nous mais moins entouré
moi en premier lieu je pensais dire ça
c'était c'est ce que j'avais dit
à titiller le jour de son enterrement
parce que ça parle de lui parce que ça
parle de des terroristes aussi donc ça
fait vraiment ensemble c'est l'occasion
qui nous est donnée de pouvoir dire ce
qu'on a à dire on cette occasion là va
pas se représenter et si tu fais pas tu
veux si tu le fais pas enfin voilà en
tout cas ça me faire du bien si on le
fait pas on moi je sais que je le
regretterai ça n'apportera rien si ce
n'est à eux ça n'apportera rien ou le
but c'est que pour nous ça nous apporte
pas de l'avoir fait moi je sais que
c'est plus des trucs
c'est plus des choses à leur dire
directement
déjà le fait d'être au bord là on sera
déjà proche d'eux c'est peut-être la
première fois on sera le plus proche
d'eux et je veux absolument
tous les regarder dans les yeux un par
un je voudrais bien le soutenir le
regard à tous juste les regarder dans
les yeux et après on verra
je pense que pour certaines victimes
il ya une volonté de au cours du procès
de
d2 d'être confronté aux auteurs d'être
confronté aux accusés et de leur faire
savoir ce qu'ils ont vécu de leur faire
entendre par leur voix directement le
traumatisme qu'ils ont subis et la
réalité de ce qu'est une victime je dois
préparer mon témoignage et le construire
oui parce que je sais qu'en plus ce sera
un moment même si j'ai l'habitude de
prendre la parole en public ce sera un
moment très émouvant très difficile et
donc j'aimerais suffisamment le
construire et le préparer pour qu'il y
ait des choses qui me paraissent
importants qui passe même si je perds
mes moyens et ce qui est normal même si
l'émotion le dernier moment fait oublier
des choses moi je me souviens de
souvenir très précis de votre part de
tout ce qui s'est passé
mais beaucoup parler des autres que les
moments d'attentes de l'inquiétude de
savoir ce qu'on devait faire je peux
vous je veux pas vous faire revivre les
choses non plus pas de problème
j'ai des images très très très marquante
terrible quoi j'ai jamais dit qu la
guerre non j'ai pas d'idée ce que ça
peut être la guerre mais de tout de
suite compris que certains attendent en
fait moi j'avais compris les premiers
coups de feu sur moi c'était pas un
règlement de compte s'est évadé betar ce
qu'un attentat
vous avez eu la présence d'esprit de
partir en courant ce de salon je me suis
jetée au sol alors c'est là où je me
suis rendu compte que je sais pas me
jeter au sol ses intestins métier
donc je me suis fait super mal au genou
ce qui paraissait complètement anodin
par un pense que tout le monde y
vivaient autour de soi mais je me suis
jetée au sol ils ont vidé leurs premiers
chargeurs et prononcer y avoir des
blessés autour de moi je voyais mes amis
en temps je sentais mes amis on essayait
de se toucher
ils sont arrêtés à une première fois là
j'ai vu les gens devant moi ramper pour
aller vers une porte qui était en face
de nous donc j'ai commencé à ramper
aussi ils ont recommencé à tirer une
deuxième fois et là j'ai eu un vrai
sentiment de puissance totale en me
disant voilà ta j'attends la mort
puisque c'était il pleuvait les douilles
il y avait des douilles et débats non
tour de nous pas tellement il tire et
l'odeur la poudre très fort l'odeur du
sang qui commençait les cris des gens
les hurlements extraits des gens je me
lâche je me suis retrouvé allongé à côté
d'un couple où le mari couvrait sa femme
et elle était forcément terrifié quoi
j'ai vraiment neigeux deux des
terroristes et y en a un que j'ai
vraiment très bien vu et il était
tellement calme ils n'étaient pas en
fait on est imaginaire budget à liszt
barbu qui tirent en l'air
comme un hystérique n'est pas du tout
c'était il était hyper calme c'était un
militaire qui faisait son double quoi ça
ça m'a beaucoup choqué ça m'a beaucoup
choqué
qu'un français jeunes tirent sur deux
jeunes français peut-il y avait beaucoup
de jeunes
sans ça provoque aucun affecte ni de
joie ni deux c'est donc là ça m'a
beaucoup fait réfléchir
on a vu des choses très très lieu quand
même donc il faut le rappeler c'est pas
que c'est pas que des mots le pire
attentat depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est des images aussi et selon
des images
je pense que c'est important que les
prévenus longtemps
que certains des prévenus surtout des
logisticiens des gens qui disent qu'ils
ont prêté leur voiture c'est pas vrai à
l'entendre ce que ça fait marrer les
gens voient la notation l'important
c'est pas qui vous entends l'important
c'est que vous leur disiez
peu importe ce que ça le fait ce qui
serait très très compliqué c'est qu'on
perde de vue qu'on a des accusés a jugé
donc voilà la justice doit passer
vous cette rigueur judiciaire permet de
dire aux terroristes ou vous trouviez
quel que soit le temps qu'il faudra vous
serez arrêtés et vous serez présenter
devant une cour qui vous jugera
publiquement conformément au droit c'est
un principe qu'il faut absolument
respecter parce que sinon on risque de
tomber dans un arbitraire qui sera
souhaité pour permettre aux accusés il
ya ceux qui les soutiennent de justifier
leurs actions une fois de plus et c'est
justement ce justification qui serait
tout à fait inacceptable c'est pas parce
que ils n'auront pas notre haine qu'on
n'a pas envie que la justice
frappe avec toute la force dont elle est
capable nous on veut que l'état de droit
montre toute l'étendue de sa force et sa
puissance face aux terroristes tout ce
qu'on a toujours demandé c'est qu'en
revanche on ne dépasse pas l'état de
droit pour aller demander des mesures
d'exception
[Musique]
c'est très particulier une cour
d'assises on est un peu le temps est
suspendu il ya certains protocoles ya
une certaine solennité et
ça à la fois fascinant parce qu'on a
l'impression de suivre une pièce de
théâtre
puisqu'on ne sait pas à l'avancé ce qui
va se passer
donc est l'éternel surprise
de ce qui se passe avec une dynamique
qui va dépendre beaucoup à la fois des
différents interlocuteurs parce que
c'est une pièce qui se joue en temps
réel avec entre des experts les
protagonistes est aussi le
la cour
un procès c'est une co fabrication avec
des acteurs qui peuvent avoir des
stratégies peuvent avoir une manière
d'aborder le procès très différentes et
donc on n'a pas affaire à une à une
magie du procès
on a affaire à un moment judiciaire
qu'il peut dévoiler des moments humains
particulier
il ya des moments clés
les dépositions des victimes sont
souvent des moments très très fort
le nombre de passes des civils
tel qu'il sera dans le procès des
attentats
donc de novembre sera un vrai problème
pour le président un problème d'
équilibre entre eux
les différentes parties
parties civiles accusent et mai
là la différence numérique ne doit pas
amener un déséquilibre du procès
ma crainte est partagée par d'autres
confrères évidemment de la défense c'est
que avec un procès d'une telle ampleur
avec un nombre considérable de victimes
ce procès soit d'une certaine manière
détournée vers quelque chose d'essentiel
mans cathartique et qu'on peut être
s'éloigne un petit peu de la véritable
réflexion juridique
[Musique]
puis par la suite vous avez cette étape
de la reconstruction de l'enquète et de
l'interrogatoire des témoins témoin
issus des services de sécurité témoins
issus des familles et donc vous avez une
multiplicité de récits qui vont
s'entrecroiser et qui vont
s'entrecroiser à travers un récit finale
qui va être celui du 3
[Musique]
alors quand il ya des choses que j'ai
envie d'aider des séquences que j'ai
envie de
quel j'ai envie d'être présente pour le
contexte s'il ya des gens de la dg ici
qui témoignent sur le contexte est tout
simplement ça m'intéresse que c'est une
chose l'organisation de la minuad qui
étaient les donneurs d'ordres comment
était organisé les katiba voilà
vous avez beaucoup là dessus j'ai
beaucoup du tube dessus je me suis
j'ai voulu rationaliser et j'ai voulu
comprendre parce que c'est pas voilà
c'est arrivé c'est dommage alors oui ça
mais c'est pas que c'est comme ça il ya
les enchaînements il ya des responsables
il ya des conséquences et si on veut
éviter que ça se reproduise il faut
reprendre depuis le début l'ensemble de
la chaîne d impliquer de ce qui a mené
un attentat de ce niveau là c'est que
pour nous il est important qu'on parle
des prévenus de l'organisation dont il
faisait partie des raisons qui font
qu'il ya des attentats à paris à ce
moment là et ces attentats qui vient
pourquoi ils viennent comment s'est
organisée qu'est ce qui aurait dû se
passer les victimes des victimes qu'est
ce qui leur est arrivé et les accusés ça
ça doit être notre procès
le moment d du réquisitoire et des
plaidoiries est un moment très fort on
s'achemine vers la fin du procès et la
gérer chacun
amène ses arguments
chacun sait que ces arguments vont être
contré par l'autre partie chacun avance
ses pions nos arguments de tes doigts
riz en 2014 2015
ils ne sont plus
valable évidemment aujourd'hui plaidions
l'idéaliste passionnés
qui part sur une zone pour défendre des
valeurs se battre contre bachar el-assad
vouloir faire de l'humanitaire c'était
grands axes
qui finalement se sont avérées à la fois
inefficace très contesté
et mais ça nous a appris qu'en réalité
c'est une matière dans laquelle il faut
impérativement faire du droit
[Musique]
le délibéré aussi est un moment fort de
discussions parfois offre parce que
on n'est pas d'accord il ya des
discussions
dans nos juridique est aussi
la façon dont on a chacun voit les
choses c'est le secret du délibéré ce
secret qui est lui aussi un objet de
fantasme on juge sur des faits avec des
règles de droit mais on en appelle aussi
à l'intimé conviction
à ces échanges ces discussions jusqu'au
moment où on arrive au vote puisque
chacun vote
de façon secrète les pas rare qu'il y
ait 300 400 questions
et puis et puis il ya le dépouillement
de ces votes avec les réponses oui ou
non à chacune des questions qui fait qu'
on arrive à déterminer
qui est déclaré coupable qui est déclaré
innocent quelle peine
qu'elle graduation
ce sont des moments très forts
pour les accusés eux-mêmes et puis aussi
pour pour les parties civiles
[Musique]
c'est une satisfaction pour la justice
que le crime ne soit pas
impuni c'est une satisfaction aussi pour
l'avenir parce que on a le sentiment
quand même qu'on a arrêté des gens très
dangereux et que la justice va tout
faire pour les mettre hors d'état de
nuire et de recommencer la société
attend beaucoup de la sanction finale
ceux qui vont suivre le procès attendre
autre chose sans doute et les victimes
encore autre chose je pense qu'il est
important de savoir que ces gens ont été
bien jugé et ont été jugés avec nos
codes à nous de démocraties occidentales
et de nos valeurs que sont celles
prônées par la justice je pense que ça
c'est fondamental
il est important de montrer que que
c'est la liberté qui était visée parce
que c'est ça que vous voulez les
terroristes et que c'est la liberté qui
aura le dernier mot et le dernier mot
c'est aussi le procès vous avez agi de
manière effroyable vous allez être
condamné de manière démocratique
bonjour
bonjour vous allez vous installez vous
nous laissez les quatre places qui sont
là
bonjour
chers fanuel charest manuel nous vous
présentons donc les élèves de sont des
élèves de terminale qui ont pris
l'option droit et grands enjeux du monde
contemporain et donc qui finit si tout
doucement en droit puis mois de
septembre et avec eux nous nous sommes
interrogés sur les fonctions d'un procès
pour terrorisme pour la société dans son
ensemble
les questions la manifestation de la
vérité celle du jugement et des
condamnations celle de la réparation
s'il est possible celle de l'état de
droit auxquels nous sommes attachés
bonjour quand je me retrouve partie
civile dans un grand procès de
terrorisme et au début j'avais je savais
pas ma place je la connais toujours pas
mais le fait est que à force de suivre
les procès de terrorisme
le processus semble leur a parlé le
procès des attentats de janvier 2015 je
me suis dit que la partie civile aussi
avait un rôle qu'elle devait être là
pour s'exprimer pour être entendu pas
pour crier vengeance mais parce que on
vient jugé finalement quelqu'un qui des
gens qui ont
qui ont changé ma vie à tout jamais qui
ont détruit des vies moi je m'appelle
francesca bonjour déjà merci beaucoup
d'être là j'aimerais savoir si vous
auriez aimé que la peine de mort soit
rétabli pour ce genre d'atrocité pour
ces pour condamner ces actes inhumains
non je souhaite pas leur condamnation à
mort après dans ma position entre
guillemets c'est facile puisque j'ai
survécu et ce procès justement il doit
pour moi c'est le plus bel exemple de
montrer que bas nous notre justice elle
reste ferme et ça reste la justice des
hommes la fondation ces gens là elle
lancera d'autant que plus juste j'espère
qu'elle sera forte j'espère qu'elle sera
importante elle sera d'autant plus juste
qu'on leur a donné les moyens de se
défendre en fait j'avais une question
par rapport plus largement à la fin la
guerre qu'ils mènent contre le
terrorisme est-ce que vous pensez que
ces procès ils vont vraiment changer
quelque chose à tout ça oui c'est juste
un peu des pions enfin que moi qu'on
accusait mais qui mérite un heureux
de ma position au départ c'était
souhaiter ça changera rien du tout quand
je fais le bilan maintenant pour ma part
j'ai appris des choses qu au procès je
n'aurais jamais apprises oui j'ai eu des
informations notamment sur les derniers
instants de mes enfants ça c'est
vraiment le point le le point capital
que j'ai que j'ai découvert et procès il
est décisif pour moi parce que si on
regarde quel terrorisme si on regarde ce
que je cherche les terroristes et c'est
ce que j'essaie de comprendre est ce que
j'ai compris c'est qu'ils essaient de
montrer quand même que
ils essaient de détruire notre société
ils essaient de détruire ce qu'est notre
société c'est à dire un état de droit
une démocratie
dans laquelle
il ya des valeurs et parmi ces valeurs
il ya la justice
[Musique]
vous installez vous voulez
moi en tout cas je suis obligé de me
mettre ici c'est pas pour faire le
serait mieux si mais bon est-ce que
c'est le moment de poser les questions
fermées sur la circulation en général on
est bien d'accord que pour l'accès
classique par l'air il n'y a pas que les
rédacteurs qui peuvent passer j'aurai
toute la presse accréditée toute la
presse et enfin louis presse et
techniciens et
où pourra-t-on faire des interviews
a besoin de trouver ces trois le but
c'est d'avoir entre la l'entrée de la
salle et la salle des criées un espace
qui brident place mais c'est pas non
plus avec sensible donc c'est d'éviter
d'avoir une organisation anarchique à
ces endroits là et permettre la fluidité
permettent les gens de sortir de rentrer
qu'à la justice a conscience qu'il faut
que ce procès soit parfait j'allais dire
sur le plan juridique nous aussi on il
faut que le procès soit parfait sur le
plan journalistique
ce qui est important c'est que nous
puissions retranscrire le mieux possible
aux citoyens voilà ce qui se passe ici
on est des relais donc c'est important
que ça se passe bien pour nous de
manière à ce que le public nous publics
soient correctement informés par la
suite sur la publicité de l'audience on
a quelque part besoin de vous
en présence des responsables mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça ça veut dire qu'on
fera en sorte vous ayez les moyens de
travailler les plus
confortable possible parce que vous vous
êtes essentiel là c'est pas la réussite
mais c'est la conduite de ce procès et
ça on en a totalement confiance dans la
salle d'audience il ya la fois beaucoup
de noms des personnes c'est à dire qu'il
ya tous les acteurs du procès et en même
temps le public n'est pas là il n'y a
pas de télé il n'y a pas de
retransmission en direct ça se fait
voilà dans l'enceinte d'une salle
d'audience ses propres à la justice
française notamment et s'adonne à la
presse judiciaire une responsabilité
particulière personne ne veut prendre en
photo personne ne peut enregistrer et
derrière tes consorts il ya à nouveau à
nouveau le brouhaha de et là c'est la
clé c'est là que les médias nous tombe
dessus nous interroge donc il ya
vraiment deux deux o'neal à la zone du
procès la cour la salle où se tient la
cour et l'extérieur proche dans lequel
l'a par contre il ya une dissonance
complète puisque là il brouhaha il ya
des questions et les journalistes
et nous allons nous nous trouver aussi
confronté à cet
assaut médiatique avec des
sollicitations à toute heure du jour et
de la nuit où chacun veut dans
l'immédiat les réactions on les
voit là on veut toujours on veut savoir
ce que nous avons à dire ce que nous
pensons ce que et tout ça immédiatement
tout de suite et maintenant et donc
c'est une vraie difficulté à laquelle on
est confronté
il faut qu'on explique comment la
justice française s'empare de sa comment
ou juste ça pourquoi on condamne ou pour
qu'on en a qui tu es donc pour moi voilà
pour moi c'est fondamental de se dire
qu'on couvre et concours sur la durée
mais c'est une vraie question de savoir
comment maintient l'intérêt est ce qu'on
ne l'as pas est-ce qu'on ne sert pas
trop d'horreurs le matin au petit déj à
8 heures du matin évidemment que c'est
une question qui se pose est évidemment
qu'on l'a en tête ça c'est ce serait
faux que dira le contraire je pense que
c'est tout le défi des journalistes que
de naviguer entre ces deux éléments là
en fait il y aura forcément un
retentissement dans la population
maintenant s'il peut être de deux ordres
soit de rejet parce que les gens n'ont
pas envie de revivre ils sont passés à
autre chose ce que ce qu'on comprend
tout à fait ce qui est difficile à
entendre pour les victimes parce que
nous n'avons pas réussi à passer à autre
chose mais mais on peut comprendre que
la société ait les oublis envie
d'oublier de passer à autre chose
et
ça va être intéressant de voir comment
la société civile va accueillir ce
procès
[Musique]
ce procès sébastien débutera qu'en
septembre prochain mais le palais de
justice de paris commence déjà à s'y
préparer à deux mois de l'ouverture du
procès des attentats du 13 novembre les
victimes les oignons durée du 8
septembre à la fin mars 2022
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce
processus je vous le demande enfin assez
j'ai une réponse et une rep si on
atteint un résultat du procès
à part ça va être des condamnations de
gens qui de qui nous qui me sont
indifférents en fait finalement
moi
ce qui se passe c'est que dans ma vie
dans notre vie il ya eu l'intrusion de
ces gens là dans notre vie
et donc
c'est
fini on est lié quelque part on est lié
quand même dans cette affaire la vie
nous a
fait nous croiser ils ont croisé ma
fille mais nous croiser et le procès
c'est
ça permet quand même pour moi ça me ça
fait partie de mon histoire de notre
histoire c'est tout j'accompagne le
procès se sont l'important c'est le
témoignage je reviens sur le témoignage
parce que là faut que la cour faut qu'on
vive tous à travers l'amiante j'imagine
le président est là devant moi la cour
les accusés sont acquittés suis juste
dit m oui
sont là le la crise l accusation et là
moi je suis en face et je fais est ce
que je peux
être au fait de moi si je témoigne pour
vous dire c'est à dire que je témoigne
bien sûr je vais parler de ma fille
c'est à dire que dans ce ce procès je
suis face à des individus qui ont perdu
de leur superbe qui vont être dans le
box
et c'est c'est cétacés
et gens là que je m'adresser c'est à
dire que eux quand ils sont venus et
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont semé la la la la
la la terreur dans paris enfin qu'ils
ont tiré dans le tas ils ont tiré dans
le tas c'est à dire que pour eux c'est
ccdh lab c'est de l'anonymat qu'ils ont
en face et nous en témoignant quand je
vais venir témoigner je sors de
l'anonymat
ma fille
la famille c'est ça c'est à eux que je
m'attache la cour ok je vais m'adresser
à la com est-ce que je peux leur c'est à
eux que je veux parler cet aveu que je
veux
l'écouté
devant les cours d'assises on s'adresse
au président on s'adresse pas aux
accusés mais la goutte est fait chez
tard et votre coeur moi c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est très important
pour moi c'est quand j'ai su l'âge de
ces jeux de c2c de ces minables de ces
minables en fait qu'ils sont de la même
génération que bashung la même
génération que mes enfants donc ça c'est
une partie sur laquelle moi je voudrait
voilà c'est un autre axe sur lequel je
voudrais
jouer mais que je voudrais développer
parce que ça va ça me pose en tant que
maire en tout cas et en tant que ça me
pose question
est ce que est ce que par exemple je
peux
je peux mettre j'ai envie d'avoir la
photo de ma fille oui oui si on peut
prendre et la rélève photos que vous
aimez mais je voulais vous lamentez
grandi avec la plume du bonsaï
minima
mais d'ailleurs moi en regardant toutes
les photos d
les photos de beaucoup de
deux victimes il ya beaucoup il ya le
regard je trouvais que ça aurait été
bien
tous commencer par enfant moi je ne peux
pas j'arrive je jouais sur l'enfance moi
je sais pas mais c'est personnel c'est
moi j'ai l'amiral sa vie s'est arrêtée à
30 ans et j'étais en étant dit je ne je
n'ai je ne peux pas je n'arrive pas à
revoir à revoir ses photos enfin je ne
peux pas je je je refuse parce que
l'enfant l'enfant il est petit on le
voit grandir
enfin on jette
et revoir ces photos c'est à dire savoir
qu'elle est terminée c'est fini j'ai en
la regardant petit
geste à la fin de sa vie gg gg 13
novembre 15 je peux pas j'arrive pas
[Musique]
où
lire un procès verbal dans laquelle une
victime à déposer et puis l'entendre
déposé devant la cour d'assises je
verrai il ya un abîme
[Musique]
une victime
souvent avoir beaucoup de mal à à dire
mais à la fois elle a du mal mais une
fois qu elle dit elle dit beaucoup de
choses
parfois et ça se voit dans le public
what
les larmes les remet poule
[Musique]
où
donc ici se mettent ils famille jusque
là il était fasciné
quasiment pour partir d'ici
[Musique]
martin houle éviter dire que de chaque
côté avant
c'est ici le témoignage fait ici je
serai en fait je serai là je mettrai une
petite chaîne prendra je me vois pas
m'asseoir non
mes garçons et ce qu'ils peuvent être à
côté de moi je veux dire quand on va
venir témoigner que je peux avoir oui
ouais mais tu vois là en fait j'aurais
voulu être 20 j'imagine tu vois si
j'étais là par exemple et pour voir
comme away we parce que oui parce que du
coup il est de dos quoi le témoignage il
doit pouvoir et d'un autre côté
d'un autre côté maintenant que je suis
là
je me refuse de donner ces détails mais
c'est vrai que là ça me permet aussi de
ne pas avoir la pression des parties
civiles et des avocats cette densité en
fait je suis seul avec eux avec la cour
ah oui ouais là je vois tu vois c'est
bon j'ai pas les avocats dans le dos
j'ai pas tous est que les journalistes
les ouais je pense une espèce de une
espèce de bulle là qui oui kim
je me vois en situation voilà et ça me
conforte
[Musique]
vous êtes ici dans la régie
la régie à partir de laquelle les débats
seront
enregistrées pour l'histoire la régie à
l'intérieur de laquelle fonctionnera
l'enregistrement des débats à partir de
la web radio vous avez en tout huit
caméras qui permettent de faire cette
prise de vue le même programme vidéo
sera retransmis dans toutes les salles
il servira aussi à montrer les débats
aux personnes qui sont au fond de la
salle sur les écrans du fond de la salle
vous aurez ce ce programme qui sera
mélangé par un réalisateur dans la régie
avec les personnes qui parlent les faits
sa conviction un événement avec une
vision parfaite de la salle d'audience
dont la captation historique n'a pas
vocation à faire entrer dans l'histoire
les magistrats c'est de faire entrer
dans l'histoire les débats
l'histoire du terrorisme en france il
est évident qu'il faut permettre
à ces débats d'être filmé
il faut que ce procès ait lieu pour eux
la france elle-même qui a connu une
épreuve considérables et donc tout tout
connaître et tout savoir et aussi pour
les générations nouvelles
les grands procès au cerveau aussi de
pédagogie d'où l'importance de les
filmer de l'es2 les données de les
relater et est de faire en sorte que ça
puisse être transmis aux nouvelles
générations
ce procès n'a pas le choix il doit être
historique
il doit être historique parce que il
représente
un élément traumatique de notre pays où
on est dans une attaque concertée
prémédité extrêmement froides
extrêmement organisés je crois aussi
qu'il est historique car la cour
d'assises aura à se questionner sur
les raisons qui ont conduit
une jeunesse a assassiné
ses pairs assassiné
la jeunesse
[Musique]
bonjour à tous la justice face à la
barbarie le procès s'ouvre aujourd'hui
un moment de vérité des années de
souffrance pour les victimes et leurs
proches un traumatisme national un
pardon souvent impossible et un immense
désir de justice
[Musique]
et
quelque chose se passe normalement
calmement
que les choses aient lieu comme elle
doit avoir l'air triste d'ailleurs dans
la dignité que chacun ait sa place
que chacun puisse s'exprimer que nous
devions se passe de la manière la plus
normale possible
si c'est ainsi sous sa réussite
[Musique]
ce procès c'est quelque chose qu'on le
doit la totalité des victimes depuis
cette soirée du stress avant
c'est le devoir élémentaire de la
justice de pouvoir expliquer aux
victimes ce qui s'est passé en nommant
les choses en désignant les coupables et
en les punissant
c'est important pour retrouver les
constructions non
la reconstruction ça a été un travail
beaucoup plus intime que ce qui va se
jouer là je dirais que c'est beaucoup
plus sain
un travail sur la confiance dans les
institutions démocratiques dans la
confiance du pacte républicain qui en
france et sur la possibilité de tous
vivre ensemble dans cette période de
terrorisme
[Musique]
non
faut qu'ils aient lieu ce qu'on sait
c'est ça fait partie de l'histoire
c'est pas une finalité
mais ça fait partie du chemin
[Musique]
il
le 13 on a eu l'impression de descendre
dans un puits et on remonte petit à
petit parfois on descend et on se
rapproche de la lumière de là on est
aidé avant le procès ça fera une des
étapes une des dernières que je
tournerai sur ce qui m'est arrivé le 13
[Musique]
le faire quelquefois aussi le fait de
tourner des pages de se dire ça y est ça
c'est fait on tourne une page de mon
métier dur de tourner les pages c'est
celle enterrés un peu plus en fait aussi
parce que finalement il est encore
vivant car à travers tout ça
à un moment si on aura tourné toutes ces
pages et on leur a définitivement
enterré jean-jacques
restera nous
[Musique]
non
on
[Musique]
il